Most of you probably ran into the Fibonacci sequence of numbers,
named after filius Bonacci in a previous computer science class.
It's a great way to teach recursion.
Here I've written out a Python definition for the Fibonacci sequence.
To get the Nth Fibonacci number, well, if N is less than or equal to 2,
we just return 1, otherwise, we return the sum of the 2 previous entries.
So we're going to get 1, 1, 2 -- 1 + 1 = 2.
1 + 2 = 3.
2 + 3 = 5.
3 + 5 = 8.
5 + 8 = 11. That sort of thing. Did I do that correctly? Let's imagine. [Laughs]
No, I totally didn't do that correctly. Man, you can't take me anywhere.
[Singing--hmm, hmm, hmm] Basic math. Don't mind me. There we go.
This looks a lot better. You saw nothing.
Alright, so there's our Fibonacci sequence.
In an incredible surprise move, it actually shows up a lot in nature--
for example, in the patterns of seeds in a sunflower or in the whirls in a clamshell
or in yellow chamomile plants or all that good stuff.
However, Fibonacci involves a huge amount of work.
Let's go see what goes on when we call Fibonacci.
I'm going to abbreviate it with an f--Fibonacci of 5.
Well, that's going to be based on Fibonacci of 4 and Fibonacci of 3.
Now 4 is based on 3 and 2. 2 is a base case, so we're done. 3 is based on 2 and 1.
Over here, 3 is based on Fibonacci of 2 and Fibonacci of 1.
If you look carefully, a lot of these get repeated many times.
We end of calling Fibonacci of 2--once, twice, 3 times I called it.
Similarly, Fibonacci of 3 is called multiple times.
We're redoing work.
We're computing the value of Fibonacci of 2 and Fibonacci of 3 over and over again.
That is wasted work. We want to be lazy and avoid that.